well i'm joined now by hosnian jalil the
former afghan deputy minister of women's
affairs uh what is the latest that you
are hearing about the situation now for
women in afghanistan
um
since just a few moments a few laughs
the last few more minutes that i've been
in touch with the uh my ex-colleagues my
with my friends my family in afghanistan
uh
they are in the middle of
the conflicting statements of taliban
with their
practices on the ground
so they give reassuring messages
um
on giving women
their basic rights or
women's basic rights but their action on
the ground or their practices on the
ground or different
so they are scared they are scared of
going back or being imprisoned in their
houses uh like they used to during the
taliban regime back in
2001
but at the same time they are given
reassuring messages
of having access to education and having
access to health centers and not being
they don't have to be accompanied by men
uh but they are in the middle of uh i
would say evaluating it in the middle of
a feeling how to evaluate a taliban
based on their ground realities or based
on their uh
i would say statements
and they're also afraid of the fact that
they might be uh giving these reassuring
messages just to make sure that they
would uh that the taliban might have
might need a peaceful transfer of power
and as soon as the international forces
are out of afghanistan the six thousand
forces we have and as soon as
afghanistan becomes irrelevant to to the
international community again all the
doors will be shut for them
we saw a video today one of those videos
you've been talking about the taliban
talking to female workers and hospitals
telling them that they are are safe to
work but
you know you're saying the fear on the
ground is real but but as far as you
know is the situation on the ground
different i mean there have been rumors
about women being mistreated but have
you heard any of that personally
i do we still have i've been in touch
with uh some in her rot we still have
i mean women uh i mean haven't been able
to go to universities schools although
some of the government um
offices they could they they assume that
they're uh they resumed their their
office their normal operations
but the women they haven't been able to
go to work to go to school to go to uh
universities but if we are uh speaking
of the healthcare provider service
providers or women in the health center
uh in the yeah in the health centers or
hospitals that has been part of the
taliban's policy even
during their their first round of ruling
registry
my mom was a medical doctor and she
could uh put surf in the hospital so
that is not different that doesn't make
them different from their first round of
i would say regime
um
in terms of the afghan government that
has existed there for the last 20 years
figures are being pointed obviously in
america for pulling out but how much do
you think the afghan regime itself was
to blame for not standing up to the
taliban
uh
there's one thing in the government the
political system the other thing is the
um the afghan national defense and
security forces
when it comes to the political regime
when it comes to the whole political
system i would say we share the
responsibility and we hold ourselves
accountable equally together with our
international allies
but when it comes to the afghan national
defense and security forces with all the
flaws we had with all the i would say
gaps we had with all the weaknesses we
had
because i've served them for more than
two years and i've had the chance in
order to calculate
our strength and our risk it's as well i
would say we could resist i would say we
could defend
i i again have to repeat myself we
haven't lost the the war um literally we
have lost it uh politically
and we do share the responsibility and
accountability equally we hold ourselves
accountable equally
do you think ashraf ghani um his
leadership was ineffective
uh
it's very difficult to to make a
judgment or to jump a conclusion before
we hear at least a statement after he
left the palace
um i i can't make a comment right now on
on uh on the effectiveness of his
leadership managing the whole situation
the very recent political situation i
can't make a statement i would say the
reason is because i may not have
sufficient information to do so
um in terms of your role uh in the
government and the rebuilding of women's
place in society after so many years of
being subjugated by the taliban how how
great a task was it
to to convince women
that that they were able to get back out
have an education take a much more
active part in society
uh
well definitely in in major cities it
has been of course um a different
provinces depending there are many
factories of
that affects the whole i would say
efforts that we have been making in
order to make sure that women are aware
of their basic rights
uh their basic rights of access to
education access to health their food
security shelter access to
justice
i would say employment and at the same
time
security
we needed to make sure that they are
aware of their basic rights but at the
same time they are claiming these rights
that matters
so depending on province by province
district by district village by the
village it could defer because there has
been different variables different
factors that could affect that
but i would say um we i mean because i
i've also been involved in peace
consultation with women across provinces
and all i could hear from them as the
red line with the in the peace
negotiations has been the very basic
rights of education and access to health
services and justice
so i would say it hasn't been a
difficult task to convince women to
claim their rights and they equally
shared the same concern they equally
wanted the same rights
and in terms of what happens now in
afghanistan there is obviously concern
about the taliban and whether or not
this will erode women's rights and and
as you said whether or not that they
will keep calm uh until uh foreign
troops have entirely left and then
revert to how they were before but but
how great a concern is it for you also
that that afghanistan could become a
haven for other militants and other
groups who may well persecute people
inside afghanistan women included
well how afghanistan would
taliban used to be the umbrella for
others for more than other uh for for
other more than uh 20 terrorist groups
but at the same time taliban had become
an umbrella for the organized crimes
criminals
and at the same time for the narco
business and and uh
criminals as well
uh so i would say it used to be as a
group it used to be the umbrella but now
it's gonna be as the state it's going to
be an umbrella
which is i would say more dangerous and
promoting a terrorist troop to a
terrorist state
that is not just um
i would say dangerous for the afghans
but that's dangerous for the whole
international security but when it comes
to the women of afghanistan the fear i
share the same fear being someone who
has spent my childhood during the
taliban during taliban regime
and we have fought with them for the
last 20 years
i would say that they will adopt the
same policies that they used to practice
during their first round of regime and
it may be more brutal than what it was
and the reason is because sometimes i do
not sometimes but i do receive the
analysis from many experts around the
world the taliban
may have changed may look for the
international recognition but
it doesn't make sense to fight 20 years
more than 20 years to rule a nation for
uh five six years with the same ideology
which has as part of their core values i
would say it has
applying sharia law on women
and now all of a sudden i mean that's
how they've convinced their fighters to
fight for and now all of a sudden they
can't change the whole principles the
same values
uh the values that they've convinced for
years they're fighters to fight for
so i for me it honestly it doesn't make
sense to uh to believe the taliban would
change their policies towards women
towards children and their basic rights
well it's a gloomy assessment and one
can only hope that you're wrong hosna
jaleel former afghan minister of women's
affairs thank you very much for joining
us today
thank you so much for having me